là messieurs bonsoir jusqu alors nous
avions essayé de ne pas trop montrer
notre inquiétude à propos du sort
d'alain colas qui n'est toujours pas
arrivé à pointe-à-pitre mais cette fois
disons le on a vraiment peur pour lui le
bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale est revenue bredouille de sa
mission la nuit dernière
joël charpentier le trégastellois qui
est arrivé 5e ou hier et qui avait une
journée de retard sur colas
lors du dernier pointage il ya deux
semaines à confronter son journal de
bord avec celui de michel malinovski lui
aussi avait un peu de retard sur colas
et il avait choisi de la même route et
bien une certitude il est arrivé quelque
chose et peut-être quelque chose de
grave tous les radioamateurs sont
d'ailleurs mobilisés depuis quelques
heures pour essayer de retrouver le
navigateur
en tout cas pour essayer de percevoir la
moindre tentative de liaison radio
est ce que vous pourriez sur certaines
fréquences capter les radios des bateaux
sur la route du rhum celle d'alain colas
par exemple vit aujourd'hui à titre
exceptionnel nous allons droit d'écouter
les fréquences hautes que celles qui
sont radio amateur et compte tenu des
circonstances exceptionnelles
disons un peu effectivement aujourd'hui
et vous avez reçu quelque instruction
uniquement des comptes et de ne t'aimons
ô du bateau les coordonnées
géographiques de ce bateau et de
retransmettre toutes ces informations en
station côtière officielle qui eux sont
chargés de faire mes recherches après le
repérage c'est maintenant la recherche
le bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale qui avait été jusqu'ici pour
des missions de repérage des
concurrentes tête vient de recevoir la
consigne de fouiller l'atlantique à la
recherche des solitaires dont on est
sans nouvelles cette première mission de
sécurité de sauvetage est d'effectuer
hier au large de l'île aux deux coups qu
à vous êtes d'échouer gouvernail cassé
le trimaran vsd pendant deux heures
le bréguet atlantique a survolé
l'épreuve endommagée du voilier jusqu'à
fait qu'un petit canot à moteur
intrigués par le manège de cet avion se
porte au secours deux jeunes riguidel
qui est leur pays sains et saufs cette
mission accomplie le bret qui a survolé
pendant toute la journée
la zone dans laquelle on supposait la
ligue et les voiliers de cette transat
aujourd'hui un autre breguet atlantic
partie des acheteurs sur vos lui aussi
les routes de la courte mais malgré un
instrument les plus perfectionnés dans
un ferr la marine nationale
il faut bien reconnaître que sa tâche
n'est pas facile
cherchez un voilier dont son neveu n'est
pas la position depuis longtemps c'est
presque aussi difficile que de chercher
une aiguille dans une botte de foin et
c'est le cas précisément devant nous et
20 le voilier d'alagoas dont on a perdu
la trace depuis quinze jours
sa famille inquiète est intervenu pour
que des recherches approfondies soient
entreprises forcés de reprenne un proto
soir qu'elles n'ont pas abouti ce qui
commence à devenir inquiétant mais les
solitudes qui sont déjà arrivés à pointe
un clip refuse de voir en la catastrophe
et préfère penser que alain colas
victime d'un ennui dans vos techniques
rallye pointe à pitre avec des moyens de
fortune et que dans ces conditions le
retard est tout à fait explicables
oui hein